all right dwight coming from practice
didn't i get to eat yeah we're doing
this on an empty stomach that's cool
that's the best way to do it i'm good to
go okay well when you can eat what's
what are we craving what's going to be
in the meal today
it depends you know i'm pretty much a
healthy eater
so uh i really like eating a lot of
fruit
okay um i'm not vegan
uh so you know i do eat you know i have
like steaks and stuff like that but
probably some fish okay salmon
but you had some chick-fil-a i had
chick-fil-a and i fresh i knew that you
hadn't eaten
got you fries but you know the waffle
fries they have to be hot they're not
good if they're not hot they got the
best fries best fries best fries waffle
house no not waffle house i'm sorry
chick-fil-a and checkers
best fries you never had chicken spice
wait they kind of have like a lot of the
black seasoning on it like they're
vegetable oil yeah okay i have these
they don't think they're good no they're
good but i don't think i put them with
chick-fil-a are you serious i don't
think anything goes with chick-fil-a
fries you is bugging out
okay so what's your top three fries
okay obviously chick-fil-a fries
i like wendy's fries wendy's i like
wendy's these fries can be good when
they hot and you got a frosty to go with
it i did my my friends good okay okay
yes i love the sweet and salty mix okay
i don't know what rounds out my third
honestly so you don't like mcdonald's
i like mcdonald's like late at night
with the nuggets
i like that
to me mcdonald's is like drunk food
mcdonald's fries and nuggets
for me personally
yes
yeah and you know i brought you here
really just to discuss
which fries are better than the other
friends
so i'm happy we've gone down the road
okay you said you like fruit and this is
a really weird question
my best friend raven she always asks
people when she meets them she says if
you were a fruit
what fruit would you be and why
[Laughter]
that's a good one if i was a fruit what
would i be and why
oh
cause there's so many ways to go so
think about it it is that's i'm doing a
lot of thinking because i like a lot of
fruit
uh
the one that keep coming to my head is
watermelon okay
and i'm just keeping that watermelon i
just like watermelon i'm a country boy
i love watermelon i've been eating them
my whole life and then you know you put
the watermelon in the free in the
refrigerator make it cold
that's when it's banging so okay i'm
gonna go with watermelon no but you have
to say so what about you makes you
watermelon you're saying it's your
southern roots yes okay you know
watermelon is you know obviously full of
water
you know obviously you know
i'm full of water
75 just like all humans yeah 75 percent
water
i guess
a tough one to answer i'm sorry it is it
makes you think i went i go with peach i
was going to say peach second but i'm a
guy
and in georgia they say that the women
are georgia peaches yes so that's why i
didn't want to say a peach i love
peaches and nectarines and grapes
you ever had frozen grapes yes my
grandma would freeze them do you like
them yeah cotton candy grapes
no oh did you know that was a thing yes
cotton candy grapes
what is the cotton candy grape it tastes
like cotton candy but it's a grape but
it's a grape
how does the grape taste like cotton
candy they have cotton candy grapes so
it's created like this is created by
humans everything is created well no no
like grapes or fruits that like grow i'm
saying do does a human make it taste
like cotton candy do you know what i'm
trying to say
it's like a hybrid fruit created
no it's created it grows
and it just happens to taste like
concrete i grow them at my house
really i have a garden at my house
well this first five minutes is not what
i expected but i learned a lot it's okay
okay watermelon and you're a peach yes
but maybe i'm a cotton candy
watermelon and peaches at my my garden
you garden yes how often
every year i got watermelon i got
peaches i got grapes blueberries
squash eggplant
uh bell peppers figs
uh oranges apples
what yeah and you tend to this garden in
your home me and a
host of other people oh my goodness what
made you get into gardening i did not
know this well i
always want my kids to be
self-sufficient you know and just in
case something ever happens in the world
you know they'll know how to take care
of themselves you know how to garden how
to you know plow the fields and stuff
like that i also have a farm my dad is
he stays on with my mother
but
i just always wanted my kids to to be
able to be self-sufficient i also have a
rose garden at my house
i love roses
oh wow yeah you are interesting
james bond yeah because
speaking of just like things you have at
your home one of the times i have been
around you is when i interviewed danny
green
and we were playing with snakes and like
lizards and gators and i think you have
a bunch of snakes i do what's the count
out now what animals i went back during
covet i had over 40 snakes at one point
but now i probably have about 20. oh
just 20. yeah yeah i love snakes they're
really they're really calm creatures
you know you can learn a lot
you know just by you know watching the
snake you know what i'm saying so
uh snake can tell you a lot about people
the people that are around you usually
if a snake just hauls off and tries to
bite somebody that means you don't need
to have that person around because they
don't really do that yeah so
i enjoy reptiles like that i'm thinking
about one rep not a reptile but an
animal that i would love to have
cliffhanger what is it
it's a giraffe
is that bad
a giraffe in the house no not in that
like you're already tall enough around
the house
around the house just roaming yeah
amongst the garden and the yes
a giraffe why a giraffe
and is that legal here in california in
georgia i live i'm a country boy so i
got all the other animals already on lot
the cattle you know the mules the
donkeys
you know all that stuff
but i would like to have a giraffe i
used to say i was a giraffe when i was
younger i was so tall yeah giraffe and
peacocks
why peacocks have you seen the peacock
just because it's pretty it's beautiful
all these yeah i know the males those
are the males yeah the reason why they
spread like that cause they're trying to
get the women's attention let them know
how beautiful they are yeah but peacocks
are real beautiful animals so is this
why are you trying to be a peacock you
got the colored hair you colorful
fashion you're trying to channel the
peacock
no
no
i just like i love animals i'm a big
animal lover you know dogs all type of
animals
so you know that's me nice well hey i'm
adding this to the list of things i
never knew
about dwight
watermelon cotton candy grapes one a
giraffe you garden you have all the yes
and you have the rose garden but you
also actually
you want your children to be
self-sufficient it's like all in my head
now oh wow yeah we haven't even got to
the fact that you also uh are in the nba
oh yeah yeah
it's a small thing
i forgot that i played basketball yeah
[Laughter]
thank you so much for watching this
conversation is brought to you by our
friends at hbo max stream all your
favorites at hbomax.com
so tell me your names again i'm venus
i'm serena
so what you think
if you want the truth near follow me
back to the matrix
and playing some good basketball right
now carmelo
he is shout out to melo yeah
why
yeah you could you do i do the two to
the head cuz i don't shoot three
although you did like an instagram live
where you said that lebron told you what
if you get two blocks again it was kind
of like a joke
but did he sort of say something like
that he said it as a joke
but maybe two blocks a game you can
attempt to three yeah and it was a joke
and i was joking back so i said it on
live you know so everybody say oh if you
get two blocks just you know get
everybody you know get everybody going
but you know i understand my role with
the team is not to shoot threes now if
coach needed three
you could always give it to me and i'll
be ready but we have three point
shooters and you know i do my job making
sure i get those guys open shots and um
go rebound you know and i'm the i'm the
muscle of the team so it's my job to hit
guys yeah get them frustrated and then
you got lebron and all those guys come
down and finish yeah okay well i do want
to talk about mello because i love like
he's just somebody i'm happy for you
know he gets this like chance in the
league we shouldn't have not been in the
league and he's excelling
why do you think it was like taking so
long for camilla to be on a team
especially given how he's performing now
uh well
we are we gonna go are we trying to you
know we go we go into it in this show
you sure always okay
all right well i just feel like you know
since carmelo is supposed to be old in
nba years that i feel like they were
trying to you know get him out
you know
and i've always felt like he's been
great since since i've met him since
college
olympics everything he's been the same
guy
you know as far as how he plays he's
never stopped working
he can shoot the ball from anywhere on
the court
his attitude his name really speaks for
how he is he's mellow you know i'm
saying he's
real chill you know he don't
get into it unless you really rile them
up but other than that when the lights
come on and it's time to go to work he's
ready at all times and i appreciate that
about him that you know one thing he's
never changed that's the best thing
about it well so the last episode that
we had we had lou williams on the show
and he was talking about how the league
is too political and he said that melo
was a prime example of why that was
someone he felt like should have been
the league but because of all these kind
of random narratives about him he felt
like that was the thing that stopped him
from being in the league do you agree
with lou's assessment of just the nba
it's very political uh
and since i'm in it you know i want to
make sure i don't say too much
because i'm not trying to get myself out
but
i think it's it's politics and a lot of
what goes on in the nba
and um
you know it's kind of disheartening at
times it
the polit the political side of the nba
can really like
cause you to lose passion
for the game you know because it's like
man this
i can work my butt off
all summer
get better
and the coach might not play me
you know so it's like what did i do all
this for and you might not get
you might not play because
the person that plays in front of you is
the one who
is the one making the money or the one
who got the big contract and stuff like
that so it's like
hey i gotta suffer because of this so
you know it can be disheartening but
then that's when you have to really just
take your ego out put your pride to the
side and you know and realize you know
what is the what is the main goal for
this team and what we're trying to
accomplish
you know and as you know as a young
player
the main goal most the time is to try to
establish yourself
you know get to that all-star superstar
level status
and uh make as much money as you can
and then you know for the older guys you
know everybody's like well we want to
win
you know we want to win championships
but i think now like the league is kind
of it's kind of changing to where
everybody has that mindset of we can win
this championship you look at how teams
are playing
you know this some of the greatest
basketball games being played this year
you know so far every team has come out
hot
uh guys have really been working on
their games and have gotten a lot better
and it's good to see the position that
the league is going as far as the
players these young guys are really
working in it's exciting to watch
so you talked about guys having to put
ego and pride aside
can you tell me maybe the roles that ego
and pride have played in your career if
any oh okay yeah you know like i was you
know explaining earlier when you're a
young guy coming into the league
you know you go on the team and it's
like you're the man you know everybody's
you know expecting you to be a certain
way and sometimes you carry yourself
that way you know you know the man
around the big man on campus
you know and sometimes that pride you
know just like j cole said can be the
devil
it could really mess you up mentally and
spiritually you know if you don't have
yourself grounded in the right places
you know so
early in my career
i wouldn't say i was very prideful
but
a lot of people took it that way you
know by you know
maybe the way i handle myself in certain
situations so
then i look back on it like when i was
super young you know i didn't have
proper guidance you know there's not a
lot of people that come into the league
at 18.
um
getting tons of money getting a lot of
attention
you know
that's very difficult to deal with you
know unless you have the proper guidance
you know and i think that now that i'm
older you know and i've been through so
many things and the experiences that
i've gotten you know just really helped
me out and i understand like hey
you know for this moment in time just
be
who you need to be for your team
and you know everything will work
yourself out
yeah because i think when
when you kind of think about
your earlier years in your career it
just felt like it was a lot of you being
misunderstood
would you say that's accurate that's
very accurate i think a lot of us are
misunderstood yeah and the the crazy
part about it is we never have
conversations you know and people hate
what they don't understand
and so that's one thing that's
uh bothering us in america in general
you know we afraid to have tough
conversations we're afraid to face you
know someone to talk about things that
you know
may hurt people's feelings
uh it may have people
you know mad and want to you know fight
do all that stuff but we avoid that and
i think that's one thing that we
shouldn't do we should have
conversations we should open up and
understand each other because maybe you
can find some common ground by just
talking the more you talk
it's like the better you know you've
seen um
uh what's the move men in black of
course there's a scene where he was like
let's go get some pie
and so uh will smith didn't understand
why he wanted to go get some power at a
time but when they sat down and started
eating and they just had that
conversation
they started to have a better
understanding of each other
and now will and you know
agent k
uh they since they had that better
understanding they was able to fight for
each other in a better way because they
could really understand each other and
then they had the love that they had for
each other just grew
and i think that's what we all need you
know just one to spread love but that
can come with having a conversation
okay so let's get some pie
tell me
yeah
tell me
one player that you did get some pie
with and it helped you guys have a
better understanding of each other
let's say a player that we had a
conversation okay
hey i'm going with the analogy okay
shout out men in black
tell me one player you had a
conversation with and it helped you get
that understanding and one player you
wish you were able to have that
conversation with to get some
understanding who
oh well uh i would say kevin garnett
uh the player that i had a conversation
with
um we got into it a lot you know on the
court you know kg is known for
you know fighting and all that stuff and
uh there's a video of me and him going
at it you know he was playing in uh
brooklyn
and i was with the rockets you know we
kind of got into a little scuffle
and um after the scuffle uh happened i
actually saw him in houston a couple
days later
and i was like man you know what let me
go talk to him
and i went in there you know we had a
conversation i got a real understanding
of you know how he
you know treats basketball and his
teammates and guys that's not on his
team
and so you know he basically said i
don't have no problem with you but
you're on the other team and when we get
on the floor
it's basically [ __ ] you
and i and i understand that you know
like you're right
it we in battle
so you're not supposed to be my friend
when we in battle but after the game
when there's no more battle then we
still brothers
you know what i'm saying and i got a
real good understanding about that
um so
uh it was cool yeah that was cool yeah
and so that conversation really helped
you get it did and now i was like man
like because he was my favorite player
growing up yeah i wanted to be just like
kevin garnett and so when we start
playing in the league and you know every
game he's [ __ ] you
looking at me crazy
and i'm like bro what's wrong with this
man you know what i'm saying then we
about to fight
and i'm like bro like he crazy yeah but
not till i had that conversation with
him and it was a brief conversation but
the fact that we was able to sit down as
men and have a conversation it really
gave me a chance to understand who he
is as a player his character and all
that stuff because i would have never
known
unless i sat down and talked to him yeah
so i was real happy about that i love
that that it actually it worked having
that conversation improve that
relationship yes okay tell me a person
that you wish you were able to have that
kg conversation moment with that you
haven't or weren't able to
well i think me and shaq should have a
conversation
yeah because every time i see something
anyway
here
i don't know
every time
and i'm like bro why is he let me stop i
don't want [ __ ] to think i'm
i just like doing the imitation
it was pretty good
but you know it's like every time uh you
know something goes on it seems like he
has an issue with me or you know he's
talking bad about me or
giannis is a real superman
and that's what i mean he's the real
superman and nobody else i'm giving him
that name
and for me
but it's like for me it's like bro i
don't care about a superman name
it's just a name and it's so many people
around the world
who carry that name superman and it
should be bigger than just what you do
on the basketball court how you live
your life how you treat people the way
you carry yourself
you know in the public at home your
character to me that's superman you know
and that essence stands for that when i
watch the movie they said it stands for
hope
you know what i'm saying so it wasn't
something like
anything else but when people saw that
yes it's like you know i believe that i
can make it you know what i'm saying so
for me i got the superman name from
soulja boy if anything he should be mad
because he always say he the first
rapper to do everything
i got my nickname from him because
i used to
love all the soulja boy dances and the
superman song he did
and my teammates in orlando they call me
superman because i jumped over one of my
teammates one day
and i used to bench press a lot of
weight and i was like bro you really
like superman
they told me to put a cape on actually
carlos arroyo shout out to him he told
me to put a k-bar go to the dunk contest
and fly
and that's where the superman came from
with me it was never like
you know
nothing against you know or nothing for
shaq or trying to be like him or
anything like that but
if a guy wants to be like me
you know i'm welcome to the hey man let
me let me help you out let me show you
what i did to get to where i'm at and
hopefully you can take it to the next
level you know so when i see guys they
say i want to be like you i say no be
greater than me
you know be greater you know what i'm
saying that's
that's just how i took it so you know i
would love to sit down and have a
conversation yeah y'all should do that i
i know how to go yeah tell me i want to
hear it play it out
dwight let me talk to you
i talked to kobe
kobe know how i play
see phil know how i play give me the
ball and i'm gonna dunk it that's what
you gotta do
that's when you can become superman
okay
because i'm the real dunder
i'm sackalicious
i'm sick business
and everything else in rhymes
and then your response would be
sack man damn i love you bro you said
hey i'm 35 man i watch you grow up
i watch you play my whole life you know
you you know you the most dominate like
i always tell people shaq is the most
dominant
player probably to ever play
you know what i'm saying so i always
give him his props you know i never you
know would ever disrespect him any you
know but for me i love to have fun and
joke just like he do
you know so it's like that's why i'm
having a conversation like hey bro we
supposed to be like this you know what
i'm saying first of all we nba brothers
because we don't play it in this sport
it's a fraternity that a lot of people
can't get in
so for one now that we in it we're
supposed to be building each other up
not tearing each other down you know
there's too many people doing that
anyway so if you superman hell if i want
to be superman i'd be a superman too it
was more than one superman in the movie
and also he won the first superman kurt
rambis
was a superman yeah
until he came to the lakers then he was
somebody else yeah kurt i love
[Laughter]
uh you no i just
i think that'd be a great conversation
and then another one would be you know i
don't know if i should say this but
chris paul
okay yeah talk to me have a conversation
with chris paul
what do you need to say in that
conversation or what do you hope is
resolved in this conversation just an
understanding just a very good
understanding you know um
a lot of people you know
have had you know choice things to say
about chris paul um
so you know i just want to talk to him
okay can you ex can you expand on that
that's all i can say right now okay well
then tell tell me this where is your
relationship with chris paul at right
now
we don't have one okay so you more so
just want to be able to have a
conversation with chris to understand
it's just all right so for me
like i was saying about me in the shack
situation the fact that we are a
fraternity we are a big brotherhood
you know and we have to set an example
for not only
uh kids that's trying to get into the
nba
but
adults and people around the world even
children around the world
like we're stronger together
than being separate
regardless of how we may feel about
somebody personally we never know
people's lives we never know what we're
going through but the one thing that we
all have in common is that
you know we're one consciousness
we're one with one big spirit and we're
experiencing
god in the flesh and we're having an
opportunity to be individuals and
experience that
separately
so
you know just like i have a piece of god
in me he has a piece of god in him
and you know we should definitely have
conversations and hash whatever needs to
be have shot and that's with anybody
you know we should all be one we should
all be brothers we should all look out
for each other
and just turn the tide of what has been
said of the nba
in general you know around the world you
know we're all like i said we're
brothers we play this sport
uh we compete
but that's where the egos come in i
think like even with life in general
they we've always had this thing where
the politics the separation yeah left
side versus the right side
the haves versus the have-nots
the guys who make the most money guys
who don't get a chance to make the most
money starters [ __ ] players role
players it's like everything is trying
to separate us
when in actuality we need to come
together and be one
you know so
that's why
a conversation would be needed
so just for clarification this is
because i don't want your words to be
minced with this
you specifically named
chris paul
so there's something that you feel you
have specifically heard about chris
or something about you and chris that
you feel like needs to be hashed out
oh something about me and chris yeah
like me is it something you had some
kind of beef but i don't know why
okay yeah
when did this kind of beef that you're
unsure of beginning i don't know maybe
when he dunked on me a long time ago
when i was in orlando i don't know
really but there's no beef coming from
you i don't personally like he hasn't
done anything to make me have beef but
it's like we always be mad at each other
and i'd be mad at him
and we want to take his head off
looking at me like you know
what's up and i'd be like what's up you
know what i'm saying but i think we got
i just
i want to be able to change that yeah
you got to be the right examples for you
know just people around the world you
know what i'm saying and i don't want
you know all of us got kids we got
people that look up to us and it's like
well we don't need to have that it's
already too much hate
and too much bad stuff going around yeah
i want to be a part of the change no i
think this is great you're saying in a
positive way like i want us to like be
cool like and i want people this must be
cool now obviously you're not going
everybody's not gonna like each other
per se but
like i said earlier we're all one mm-hmm
you know we gotta spread love in any way
possible spread more love that's the
only way we can see god
is by spreading love yeah and that's
great because i mean you and chris are
two people that do so many great things
for the community you know i know how
heavily involved chris is with hbcus i
know you have your foundation and i
think it's great like if you guys could
kind of
all of us yeah every single nba player
should we should be tight yeah now
obviously we cut from you know different
areas we all have different beliefs and
stuff like that but the one thing that
all of us have in common
is we play for the nba mm-hmm we should
be able to
go anywhere in the world together and
build up build it up yeah because i feel
like that's what we were meant for that
was a part of our purpose of why we're
in the nba itself just imagine if all of
us came together
and built things around the united
states to really improve players games
and their minds and stuff like that
how much the world how much better
our sport would be how much
more love we would get from people
around the world because they already
feel they may feel a certain way about
us because
the amount of money we make
the status that people give us and stuff
like that so just imagine if we
you know did things like that together
not separate because we do stuff
separately everybody do their own thing
but together
would be crazy i love that
so for someone who very clearly you know
you care a lot about you know unity and
peace and you want there to be you know
synergy between all players
did it bother you when everybody saw
kind of the scuffle between you and a.d
we look here we got to squash this i
need everybody to know it's fine like
what was that like for you well it
bothered me because of how a lot of
people in the media
turned it aka steven a
bald head smith
okay i'm just playing let me stop
but i'm not sure what stephen a said so
he said a lot of shout out to stephen a
i'm not shouting them out in the in that
way but he said a lot of things you know
i think a lot of times you know stuff
like that you know as
as men you know when you're playing
basketball and you have situations
you know you got to find better ways to
handle it and obviously in that moment
both of us was you know kind of heated
but you know i realized
everybody's watching
everybody so the best thing to do
is
breathe
calm down
because you know i knew that as soon as
the next day come it was going to be
talked about everywhere yeah and the
crazy part about it was
by the time the third quarter came me
and him had already went to the back
we went to a separate room had a
conversation
and squashed it
you know i'm saying but everybody else
took it a further step
and so
like that's the thing that you know i
didn't really like you know it's just
trying to put more energy into
negativity now obviously we could have
handled that better but you got two
alpha males on the same team
you know
both of us in our feelings about certain
things
let it out
and now we good but it was just
everywhere everybody calling y'all okay
what's going on like bro you ain't
calling me in two three months
you know so it's like everybody feeds
off negativity and that's what it's like
we have to stop that you know even with
a lot of stuff that's being put out you
know in the news outlets the media like
i said about stephen a smith his
comments on that very negative
and that's one thing that
i feel as though
there's no place for that we already got
enough negativity going on and obviously
people say negativity sales and stuff
like that but how about we change that
let's sell more positive messages and
more positive things instead of always
running to something that's negative you
know if you watch just in general
something happened outside right now
somebody get hit what does everybody do
pull their cameras out
they film it person over there on the
ground passing out they about to die
but the phone's out look look at this
person look look now everybody watching
the video you seen the video you see any
person
he just died
instead of saying you know what let me
put this phone down or let me call 9-1-1
or call somebody that can help
say we just breed and off that that
negative energy and so it's like no
let's change that you know obviously
it's it's so much hate in this world
yeah so it's like why add more to it
it's like the craziest thing like just
let
got to let that negative stuff go it's a
place for that yeah and it shouldn't be
here
and i feel like so i applaud that i
think that's such a mature mindset to
have and i'm sure so many things to be
accomplished if everybody just believed
like positivity is the way to go or the
better way to go but because that's such
a mature mindset i mean did you always
see life this way or when was it a shift
for you
really i always want to spread love yeah
spread love you ever heard of someone no
me neither i just made it up
like i don't know about that one but no
i just i've always been that way you
know i don't have a ounce of evil blood
in my body you know i don't even like
killing ants or bugs my mom and them
she'd be seeing a roach and she would
have stepped on like mom no okay now the
roach the world's gotta go but what if
that roach is a papa roach he got little
kids and a wife
you can't just kill the papa roach not a
kid's gonna be saying
oh you can't do that just a very
specific thing that like can't be in
near
me okay well then take some paper and
move it out there that road's gonna find
its way back
you know roaches can like go down to the
size of like a dime and get in any space
okay
so you let the roach out that road is
coming back what i'm saying is this like
everything had that has life
and has an opportunity to live allow it
to live you don't want to dim someone's
light even if it's a little insect they
got an opportunity to enjoy this
beautiful world that we had in my
apartment
okay your apartment was placed in the
middle of where that animal or that
insect was supposed to be so actually
you were the intro
listen i'm with you on letting all
animals i love animals i got my little
puppy
but it's just like roaches specifically
that i just named it which is totally
not what you were even talking about but
i just need to do stuff i just named the
ropes but i was just saying in general
like you know we have to
just more
love and positive energy is once you the
more love you give out the more you know
positive love you're going to receive so
it's like why even want to put out
anything that's bad okay so i have to
say this
this is like the longest conversation
i've ever had with you
and
you have you're very pleasant you're
funny
you have all this stuff about this
positive mindset
why does it feel like that's not what
people know about you why is this
narrative about
because
you have the media you have all these
people who have always spoken on my
behalf and i've never spoken yeah like i
said the stephen a smiths the people who
get on tv and i feel like their job is
to tear people down that's why i'm only
naming him because i've seen a lot of
stuff that he says about a lot of people
i personally don't like that you know i
feel as though
you should always any time you're
speaking on someone and i don't even
want to speak bad on him so i apologize
if i did but anytime you have an
opportunity to stand in front of a
microphone
and millions of people can have the
opportunity to see it you should never
speak down on someone because they have
family they have friends they could have
kids anybody could be watching and when
you're saying those negative things
now what you're doing is
bringing more negative energy you're
building up all this bad energy so it's
like why even do that
so that's why that's why that's why i
was referring to him now obviously you
have
news outlets and stuff like that who
speak and say negative things i don't
even like watching the news
because when you watch the news as soon
as six o'clock news come on first thing
is it's a robbery over here there's a
killing over here it's a shooting right
here so it's like all day
we're just breathing in this negative
energy you turn on the tv that's all you
see so it's like
hey hold up now let's change this
let's start our day off with a smile i
don't even like saying good morning
because the word morning
i'm not waking up in mourning
so no i don't want to say oh i just got
it i was like what okay i get it yeah i
don't say morning i got it oh that's
yeah
so i don't want this little double
entendre i don't want to speak out no
morning yeah i want to wake up and say
rise and shine like the sun
yeah yeah we got to sing rise and shine
we got a sun inside of us the solar
plexus that's our eternal sun so when i
wake up i'm rising and shining every day
uh look at the sun i'm not mourning and
crying and going back to sleep no i
would have never thought about it that
way and i'm not gonna lie it took me a
minute i was like wait why don't you say
morning
if anyone else is slow what he's saying
is
he can't catch somebody doesn't get it i
promise you something i'll get it
when people pass away they say people be
more mourning yes
no don't wake up morning wake up smiling
wake up smile i wake up every day and
say ah thank you
i sing every morning in the mirror i
believe that one hundred percent i
believe you wake up and sing everybody i
do
okay there is something
i have to talk to you about
that you
like surprisingly i have not heard you
really discuss at length
and it is the top 75 list oh
i want you to tell me in as much detail
as possible the day that list came out
when you saw what i knew i wasn't going
to be on it
why politics
i already knew
i knew somebody made a 75 list i said
yeah they ain't going to put me on you
know put me on 75
i'm like don't forget about it
yeah
there was not even a small part of you
that felt like you're gonna be on it i
knew that they was not gonna put me on
that list
but you do believe you deserve to be on
it i most definitely should be on that
list but it's okay
it is so okay i'm not upset about it i
was for
probably like 30 seconds
i said you know what
life is great
i'm alive
i'm still playing basketball in my 18th
season who cares about a list made by
people who ain't never bounced to
basketball before
who cares
well this list i will say
seemed to be very contentious in terms
of both people who were on it and
weren't on it did have very strong
feelings like that list is something
that does represent a lot to basketball
players okay
so we're more than just athletes yeah
right yeah shout out to lebron
we're more than just athletes totally
basketball is going to be only a
small portion of our life
so i feel like a part of it could be
i'm not saying all these guys are
egotistical i don't want nobody to say
that but that could be ego i'm not on
this list this list
it's okay
yeah
it's totally fine i mean it takes a lot
to recognize that you were really a snub
someone who should have been on the list
yes i i seen all the stuff yeah
everybody said that's very crazy they
showed all my stats and numbers and
people who don't have nothing close to
it
it's okay i've been disrespected that
way since i left for orlando
so i get it
i'm not upset about it
um
i'm gonna keep working hard
i'm gonna continue to get better and
that's all that matters because the
biggest thing is the fact that
my son i'm number one to him
yeah on his list yeah yeah
that's really sweet
we're all smiling in here like ah never
wanting this i think i think that's a
good perspective and people were getting
very caught up in it there's a lot of
instagram stories and tweets and all the
things
lou that's another thing he said about
you was you should have been on it
that's building see yeah look at that
energy that was built off that
all this energy why this and that that's
people going back and forth comparing
this person to this person this person
or this person
all that is energy that's being built
in the wrong direction there's so much
things that we could
we could control we could do with that
energy that's been put out worrying
about
a list
that somebody put on
the news channel somebody had on a piece
of paper and they talked about it it's
so much energy that we could put towards
greater things than what's on the list
yeah so i rather put my energy in that
okay hey i'm trying to you're making me
more zen i'm gonna maybe try to adopt
some of these that'll always be these
ideals
let me just stay back
i just one one of the many reasons i
wanted to talk to you is obviously
because i do i wanted you to tell me
about you right because i don't think
that you have had that opportunity in
that many places i also have always been
a big fan of your game and i feel like
it gets i think that gets lost a lot of
the time because people do forget
i mean you were the
dominant nba player for such a stretch
like i remember when it was like dwight
or lebron like that was absolutely an
era um that i think people forget about
some time so when you kind of look back
at your career and the evolution of
basketball and how you know what it is
like very guard heavy now centers have
kind of changed
yeah it's all politics the even even
guard heavy you're saying it's politics
now the same things i was doing in
orlando i kid you not i can do them now
and probably even more
okay expand on that be specific shooting
yeah i can shoot the hell out the
basketball but that's not what a team
wants me to do
dribbling making plays doing all that
stuff is specifically for guys that
they've asked to do that so
that is the part of my game where it's
like now people like oh he's reduced to
this type of person or he can't do this
no i work on this stuff every day
all day
train three times a day i don't stop i
can do these things but i've been asked
to do a specific job so like i said my
pride my ego is in my back pocket
you know i'm saying i don't have to go
and show everybody hey i could still
play like this i could do this because
then i'll be out the league
i'll be sitting at home mad [ __ ]
i can do that i can do that better than
him look look
but there's no need for me to do that i
can still play i can go out there they
don't want me to go out there for five
minutes even though i want to play
longer than five minutes coach put me in
the game
even though you know if it's five
minutes if it's ten minutes i'm gonna do
it with a smile on my face and i'm gonna
go out there and have the most fun as i
can because i'm still playing the
average nba career is three to four
years
at the end of this year to be my 18th
season and i've been playing since i was
18.
so why not enjoy it why allow
all the politics and stuff which at
times you know it could really piss you
off and be like bro like come on man i
can do that
better than him yeah let's see again
that's pride yeah
and that is no place for that mm-hmm
so i mean it's clear like you are just a
fan of the game obviously you love the
game when you look at other centers
around the league the younger superstars
are superstars in the making which is
really exciting about the nba right now
there's just so much talent coming up
tell me those sinners that you look at
and you're like they're special
i think everybody's special that's just
how i look at everybody um
the guy from uh cleveland
uh moby moby evan mobley i like him
i like him i like him i like his game i
like how confident he is in himself
um
you know obviously the one guy who he's
not a young guy
but joel embiid
i think he's really good you know and
the fact that he's so mobile to be you
know seven foot two or three hundred
something pounds that it's crazy yeah
joe kitch
um
i'm happy to see clint capela and the
way he's been growing because he came in
in houston when i was there
um
but these guards some of these guards is
like like lamellar ball
not literally he was in
elementary school i think when i came
into the league and i was watching him
since he was in elementary school i was
like he gonna be the one yeah he gonna
be the one
and the boy is good just to see him go
from that level to now he's like man
he's coming in he had a triple double
against us
it was like this dude can play
basketball and just all these guys when
i see him a young fella from uh
um the clippers who don't get a lot of
attention taryn's man mm-hmm that boy
can play yeah and also he had a great
move i saw him other than i said hey man
i'm so happy for you and anytime i see a
nba player anywhere i just try to tell
you i'm happy for you dawg that's good
job man because it's so hard to get to
the nba for one people just think
because you're tall you can just make it
to the nba
it's millions of tall guys around the
world that want to make it to the nba
that's why they have a draft that's what
they have all these scouts come check
these guys
and just to see the growth of these
players and
the way that the game has changed so
much you know when i came in the league
it was only like three people doing euro
steps it was like the wayne wade yeah
manu ginobili and maybe one other person
now everybody's going to euro steps even
the coaches they warming up
what's going on but it's just crazy to
see how the game is changing how these
guys are shooting the ball so well you
look at
steph curry
just to see how crazy he shoot the ball
like
i'd just be amazed
and then he got a youngin on his team
jordan poole
who's like it seemed like in a couple
years he gonna be shooting like him and
then you look at i'm sorry for keep
talking all these young guys no i'm i
love it yeah
the guy from uh houston jaylen green
yeah he got crazy bounce
he's just a little baby
i know the ceiling is like
infinite
i watched the other day he got a dunk
and he dunked it so hard i was like man
when we play them i'm gonna give him a
fast break just so i can just watch it
you better not say that
not to kill you i'm just playing y'all
using jokes but now i really want to see
he need to be in a dunk contest yes he
got some bounce uh-huh he's just a baby
so it's just like man these boys and the
athleticism
the way that
you know i guess it's like
every decade i'd have been anyone just
my almost three decades of playing in
the nba oh wow
oh man alert i'm just kidding
two 20 yeah two decades
oh jesus i said three
that's 30 years old i'm tripping but
yeah i've been in the nba for so long
just to see how like the guards from
back then like
i played with anthony johnson
he couldn't jump over a water bottle but
he was a great he was a great i'm sorry
aj i'm just playing he was a great a
great great point guard but then now
these dynamic point guards you have the
russell west brooks and then now you see
anthony edwards
[Music]
so it's like man the game is so crazy
i'm just happy for all these guys and
the success that they're having
it's special you know i have to say
because you i think it was on instagram
you added some really nice perspective
about the philly situation so
when the hawks were playing the sixers i
was actually at the game and i saw you
courtside
and you were you were kind of there for
the ben simmons moment of the passing up
the dunk yes
or the layup whichever he would have
decided to do in that moment
and obviously his teammates kind of i
don't want to say publicly criticize him
but they discussed that moment
um and you have come to ben's defense at
some times online i just kind of want
your take on how you feel like he's
being treated well you know i felt like
a part of
me
uh i could see that in being as far as
what happened with what's happening with
ben when i was in orlando it was some
similar things happening
now
um
i just didn't like the fact that
whatever was going on on the inside had
to be made public knowledge
now obviously i'm there with ben a lot
he's one of my closest friends so i was
upset just to hear all the things that
was being said about him
and you know i just was like man
instead of saying it publicly just
address this person behind closed doors
and so now it doesn't look so bad
when we played the hawks and we lost i
was upset at being on that play
i wanted him to dunk the ball tattoo rim
down
but he didn't do it
and it wasn't just his fault that we
lost that series so my thing was we
can't just blame him we can't put all
the blame on him and then the other part
was them trying to make it or the media
trying to make it seem like it's he
doesn't like philly philly's too rough
on him and too tough on him and it's
like that's not cool because now you put
in the city against a player
and you ain't gonna win that battle
regardless of what city it is around the
united states you're not gonna win that
battle because there's so many people
who was gonna have an opinion who can
say so many things and i'm like bro
do you know how disheartening it is
to wake up and see your jersey being
burnt
as a player
or fans that you go out and do community
events with talking trash about you and
you got whole arenas saying [ __ ] ben sam
man like do you know how
that could really that could really make
you like if you're not i'm not saying
he's this but if you're not a strong
person that could really that could
really hurt you because that's really
like what a lot of kids go through every
day with bullying and stuff like that so
you never know how somebody could handle
a situation and not only that you got
his mom his dad his sisters his friends
all these people that adore him who may
not know what's really going on but now
they watching tv and all you see is him
being plastered all over tv in a certain
type of way so it's like it was like
piled on yeah so for him and for all
these people they they upset and now
they're hurt now you got all this again
negative energy being built
and it's like why why are you doing this
now
the flip side there's a lot of things
that he could have did to make the
situation a lot better
you know what i'm saying but again
that's that's where you
you do that behind closed doors you
don't make all this stuff public because
now everybody got an opinion
you know everybody has something to say
about a situation that they may not know
everything about and it's not right for
all of us to say that so if it's like if
i got family issues
we gonna discuss that inside the family
we're not gonna let nobody outside the
family know what's going on when we get
outside we smiling we dabbing each other
up
but on the inside we might have some
issues
so i felt like with that situation it
was just kind of mishandled on both
parties both sides
he could have did a way better job of
you know
on a professional side making sure you
show up and let everybody know from the
get-go yeah
but that's kind of difficult
it could be difficult you know he's 24
years old and still learning and
figuring yeah you know so
so for for someone who
is close to bad i mean how do you want
it to play out for him what do you hope
for him
i just want him to never lose himself
within all it is
because you can either go to the left or
to the right with this kind of situation
and i don't want him to lose himself and
looking around feeling
you know less confident as a person
forget just basketball just as a person
you know not wanting to go out want to
want to hide and stuff like that just
you know don't be that way then on the
other end like i said just spread it
more positive uh energy yeah you know
and i know it's hard when you know a
city is already feeling a certain type
of way
and they're upset and they want things
to happen but hell everybody want to win
a championship
only one team can win
every year so all the other cities
they're going to be mad and burn people
jerseys and
go crazy and call them out in arenas and
yes people say oh philly's a tough place
to play okay
yeah that's fine but it's also like it's
the nba everywhere it's a tough fight
everywhere's a tough place to play but i
get it but also philly is called the
city of what
brotherly love right oh my god i think
the city of brotherly love so instead of
giving out so much hate and saying this
is how we are
this is what we do
let's try something different yeah you
know i'm saying let's try something
different let's let's spread more love i
love being i like i said when we lost i
was so mad at him
hit him in the back of the head from not
shooting the ball and not you know being
aggressive but then again i said you
know what
i'mma love him enough to not say this
publicly not humiliate him or make him
feel a type of way or publicly
and if i got to say something to him
i'ma wait till i see him in person when
i'm not in my feelings
and he has calmed down a little bit and
i can tell him hey bro
you gotta man up or you gotta do this
you gotta do that that's what i feel a
true friend or somebody that you really
care about would do you would not
you know make them feel a certain type
of way publicly because you got too many
ears and too many people watching who
could build who could build their own
opinion
kind of like what you were saying about
me everybody's always said something
about me and i've nev never had a chance
to talk
so it's the same thing he hasn't spoken
about it but now the whole world has an
opinion on ben simmons without talking
to you talking to him yeah yeah no i
like to shut up i think it's important
yeah you're my dog and that's why it
goes back to what you're saying
conversation just in general are very
important um before we close out i
always want to ask is there
anything that you want to discuss or you
want to talk about that you haven't been
asked about oh no i just like answering
questions so you want to ask me
questions
i can expound on it well you've done a
great job at answering all these i have
one more though because i'm just curious
to you what this season of your life is
when i was prepping for this and looking
at articles a lot of articles were
talking about you and a would use the
term redemption like being here with the
lakers right now is redemption is that
how you view it how do you view it how
do i view being back here yeah
uh
how do i
i feel like the second time i came back
was redemption
this time is like
bro why y'all got rid of me
i want to leave l.a
i love this city man i love the fans
yeah i didn't want to we just won the
championship
i didn't want to leave
i was pissed off
when they got rid of me man
and no offense to the guys yeah i was
kind of sad but i was mad sad well i
mean you were like you're tweeting that
you
yeah
you're coming back and then
i had tweeted because as soon as it was
free agency i was like man i'm coming
back there
they gotta have me come back but then
they didn't have no
no um contract for me so i had to go
ahead and you know
i had to get ahead of me i had to go
ahead and take it back
because they had no contract yeah so um
during that process
um that's when philly reached out
and uh they wanted me to come so i was
like you know what i'm not about to wait
around
i'm gonna for sure have a job here let
me go ahead and take this yeah took the
job i had a great time in philly yeah
the fans was amazing i'm missing having
frosty freeze i don't know if you know
what that is i don't the frosty freeze
out in the fourth quarter if the other
team missed two free throws everybody
get a free frosty
no way so i was the hype man for that
that was my job
i would come in the game for the two
free throws and get the crowd hey let's
go
and if they missed the two free throws i
was hyped cause the next day yeah i was
going to wendy's and i was getting me a
big old frosting and surprise ends up to
dip yes so i missed my frosty freeze out
but it was cold and philly i do not like
snow
i love the beach and the war in the in
the sun so but i had an amazing time
there the fans was great the city was
amazing if you've ever been to you've
been to philadelphia yeah
have you been to iska bibbles no
and you got to go to esca bibles man oh
i've never heard what kind of food that
is um
it's a cheese steak philly cheese okay
but i love philly i had a great time
there um and you know every season of
mine has been great but that was really
that was a fun place to be i enjoyed
myself there i was sad i had to leave
but
i had to come home home
mm-hmm okay
i wanna they're definitely having me
wrap up but i have one more thing i want
to ask you okay because i like your
answer to that okay i'm gonna name the
teams you've been at you i want you to
give me a title of what that meant like
so if this wasn't redemption you said
it's more about coming back i'm gonna
name the teams you've been at you tell
me what that season of your life
represented for you
okay
you ready
then i'll then i'll let you go that's
gonna be tough
but it's gonna be fun okay okay
2004 to 2012 orlando magic
oh that was like
described at that moment
oh man i'm getting so old it's hard to
even remember that
oh just what did that time with the
magic represent for you it could be good
bad whatever
i for me
every city i've been in the city like
the the people there like
in the arena the
everybody that worked there it was like
joy like just pure joy like that's yeah
okay pure joy
uh 2012 2013 lakers
hell
no i'm just playing what's in here
we
see the thing was it was great i had
just came off of back surgery and i
shouldn't have played that whole season
yeah um but i wanted to play
um so
it just it just sucked man um
that we didn't accomplish you know what
we wanted to accomplish and everybody
felt like
you know i didn't want to work with kobe
and i didn't have this killer mentality
and stuff like that but i was an
all-star that year
and
i dominated
we just didn't win
and um
i think the media kind of twisted that
whole thing between me and him and me
and the team and every time they showed
us it was like he got attitude with him
but you know again it's kind of like
similar to this team now we got so many
people yeah so much talent like it take
time
and you know
things didn't happen how we wanted it to
happen but
again i enjoyed the city the fans was
great the red jackets that's what i call
them in the arena the people around the
ring of the red jackets those are my
people right there we had a little thing
that's what we do you seen that oh yeah
and then you get me yeah i looked i'm
sorry
well you you talked about just you know
being able to resolve things with
teammates do you feel like you were able
to get resolution with kobe um i think
after he finished playing you know and
we kind of like but it was crazy because
i don't think we had any issues before
that because before i went to the lakers
um i called him on the phone after we
lost in the finals and i asked him what
should i do to get better like what do
you think i needed to work on
um
like
how did he get this way what was his
attitude
and it's just like the understanding
part the people that understand like me
and kobe are two different type of
people
so the way we handle things is that kobe
is
locked in all the time he's not going to
smile on the court i can't play like
that
i can't even live like that no man look
they don't even look right on me
[Laughter]
you know but you know that's kobe he got
that that's his killer mentality
and i'm like hey
that's me so you know just two different
yeah just different styles
oh i'm happy you're able to to call him
and have that get that advice from him
okay i'll do one more
how about you tell me you want to do
hawks hornets or wizards
hawks hornets or wizards
um
who
who
hawks hornets or wizards
we'll see the wizards i had back surgery
so it was crazy there i didn't get a
chance to play
the hawks
we had a lot of talent but we just
didn't get over the top
charlotte were very young
we had a lot of young guys
and it was kind of like a transition for
all of us a lot of guys been there for a
long time then you add a new guy
like myself
and it was just we didn't mesh at the
right time but every like i said every
city that i played in i enjoyed it to
the fullest the fans the people the
people the people that was like the best
part for me doing events
um for the teams and meeting all the
fans meeting greets i love that kind of
stuff yeah so that was fun for me oh
well i had to say i have enjoyed this
you are fantastic
i appreciate you taking the time to do
this i genuinely do feel like and i hope
people that watch feel like they have a
better full scope and understanding of
you and what you're actually like
because you're funny this is the most
that i have laughed during one of these
oh my favorite yeah one hour
comedian one day hey do that 100 you're
in l.a go just stand up do a little try
it do a trial you have to well thank you
so much you know it's i think that you
have to close us out with a shaq
impression though it's only right hey
everybody uh you just got finished
watching
taylor brooks dwight howard
um
remember i'm shaquille o'neal
i'm one of the greatest to ever do it
i'm the dundada
the don dada and this is bleacher report
i'll holler at you later
peace
and that's a wrap folks
good i love it
[Music]
you